at the end of the day Trump is the wrong
kind of pushback I think in many ways
he's just like the establishment he
cares about power he doesn't really care
about things like the Constitution and
I'm concerned that he could push us in a
very dangerous direction hi I'm Nicolas
booths recent TV and today we're sitting
down with representative Justin Amash of
Michigan thanks for talking to us
thanks we're at the students for liberty
conference tell us what it between now
and 2016 what are the most important
votes for a libertarian leaning
Republican will probably have some
privacy votes coming up the encryption
bill encryption issues are hot so we'll
probably have some bill related to
encryption we're working on something in
my office to try to protect companies
like Apple make sure that the government
is going through the proper process if
they're asking for anything and not
asking companies that do things that we
think violate the First Amendment
violate what we think companies should
be required to do under this under our
Constitution what are the prospects for
growing the number of congressmen and
Senators who like yourself believe in
shrinking the size scope and spending of
government in 2016 I think it's pretty
good I mean it will depend on this
presidential election I actually think
if you get someone like Trump into
office you might actually improve the
prospects for Liberty candidates going
forward because you'll need someone
who's going to stand up to what seems to
be a more authoritarian type of system
what would so well you you brought up
Donald Trump who's leading the
Republican race as we speak and that may
or may not change you've endorsed Ted
Cruz is Trump a bigger threat to freedom
than say Hillary Clinton or Bernie
Sanders or how do you how do you work
through that math yeah and first I
endorsed Rand Paul of course and then
I've endorsed Ted Cruz now that Rand
Paul has stepped out of the race I think
that Trump presents a kind of threat to
our system that is maybe in some ways
bigger than what the Democrats present
because he's attacking from the right or
what's perceived as the right
and I think actually what he's pushing
is basically a leftist philosophy but
he's coming at it from the Republican
Party side of things so if he undermines
the concept of Liberty on our side of
the aisle and you already have the
Democrats weekend where they basically
give it up on the concept of following
the Constitution I don't know who's left
and so in some ways it could be more
dangerous who why do you think Trump is
doing so well among Republican primary
voters if he is represents a kind of
assault on limited government which is
ostensibly what Republicans believe
think there's a there's a lot of anger
out there I'm not sure it's related to
his policies it's more his his approach
they like his style
he's telling it like it is as they see
it he's telling off the people who have
been screwing them over for all these
years they they feel that Congress is
hurting them that the president's
hurting them and here's the guy who's
going to come in and make them pay for
it and I think that's populist so what's
the best outcome for the 2016 election
as far as you're concerned I think the
best outcome at this point is of course
someone like Ted Cruz because Ted Cruz
is a constitutionalist a constitutional
conservative libertarians like me have
some concerns about some of his
positions but I think we can work with
him if you have someone like Trump or
Rubio you move pretty far away from
libertarianism so what what is it about
Cruz that you can work with because and
in your endorsement of him you talked
about how he's not libertarian and
there's a lot of differences on things
like foreign policy on immigration what
is it about him that makes him different
than say a Rubio or a Trump well
philosophically he's more grounded in
constitutional principles and when you
look at its foreign policy in many ways
it's much more rooted in the ideas that
are supported by people like me and
grant Paul and Mike Lee than it is by
people like Rubio Rubio and Graham and
McCain are in their own world
they're very interventionist they
believe that you go into other countries
and you nation-build
and Cruz doesn't come from that
perspective now some of the rhetoric on
the campaign trail I think has been a
little too charged on his part but I
think he's much more rooted in
and our philosophy than he is in theirs
and I've had lots of conversations with
him I know he's a person I can work with
and he's a person I can persuade I can't
say the same of senator Rubio or Donald
Trump we are at the students for Liberty
Conference and when you were a student
what was the most important issue on
campus to you and is it still a big deal
for you for me it was probably economic
issues at the time I was studying
economics and learning about the market
learning about free markets and those
were probably the number the the top
issues form and thankfully we have
perfectly free markets now right yeah
but over time I've become more of a
civil libertarian more than I ever would
have expected and that happened because
there really was that gap I came to
Congress and found that there were that
many people protecting our liberties our
civil liberties our privacy our rights
and there are people out there talking
about economic issues but on the civil
liberties side the surveillance and
those those kinds of things there aren't
there aren't that many people do you
find that that resonates well with
students today I mean are they
interested in in civil liberties more
than economic liberties or and or do
they see them as joined it depends on
which students you talk to you but I
would say that yeah it's it's probably
more important today than it used to be
and technology has something to do with
that people are using their iPhones and
Twitter and they're concerned about
their privacy well what makes you
pessimistic these days especially
pessimistic and then what makes you
optimist well look at Trump I mean he's
doing really well in the polls and look
the fact that I have concerns about
Trump doesn't mean that the
establishment is good the current
establishment is why we have Trump they
people are fed up with them and and I've
got serious problems with them and
that's why I ran for office is to to
present some pushback against them but
at the end of the day Trump is the wrong
kind of pushback I think in many ways
he's just like the establishment he
cares about power he doesn't really care
about things like the Constitution and
I'm concerned that he could push us in a
very dangerous direction
so what makes you optimistic if anything
I look at the house freedom caucus which
I'm a member of and this is a group of
about forty conservatives and
libertarians conservatives I would say
I'm probably the most libertarian person
in that group but those folks have moved
in a much more libertarian direction
over time from when I first met them and
I think my influence has made an impact
there and I feel good about the fact
that we have a core group of about 40
people who could influence the
Republican Party because that that group
is a pretty formidable bloc and we've
been able to push back on corporate
welfare on civil liberties violations
and on foreign policy issues too and and
it's made a difference all right well we
will leave it there thank you so much
for talking to us
we've been talking with representative
Justin Amash of Michigan we're at the
students for liberty conference and I'm
Nick Gillespie for Reason TV